a beach littered with plastic spat out
by a sea that can't take much more
it's a sight that's come to symbolize
the scale of plastic pollution in Mumbai
where waste management systems continue
to fall short but these residents of the
city are trying to do their bit for
close to three years they've gathered
here on weekends to clean up this beach
their leader afro Shah is a lawyer by
training not an environmentalist but
after moving into the neighborhood he
grew tired of seeing the state of the
environment around him and took matters
into his own hands
for me I have to connect with the needs
what I've taken into the ocean till date
I do not shout out to people to come I
tell people come by choice why should
anybody shout out to protect their money
you should feel there's a problem and I
can give two hours in a week Feroz
energy Shaw's approach has slowly
gathered steam the movement is now in
its a hundred and forty second week and
has attracted volunteers from all walks
of life it's also offered employment to
about 35 workers who keep efforts going
during the week afros Shah says his
beach cleanups have cleared around
15,000 tons of plastic but it's only
just beginning to scratch the surface of
the problem activists now hope a recent
government ban on single-use plastics
here in Mumbai will help further change
mindsets the city governments
anti-plastic squads are key to the
effort clad in lead vests the squad's
work in markets throughout the city to
enforce the new bands and raise
awareness about plastic pollution
there's a lot of confusion here about
what's banned and what's not but the
anti-plastic Squad is looking to make it
clear one-time use carry bags are a
particular focus of attention some
shopkeepers and customers are heeding
the call shifting to bags made out of
cloth or jus other shopkeepers should
stop using plastic and spend a little
more money for cloth bags they are much
better and reusable plastic is harmful
for everyone but not everyone is on
board vendors at this market say the ban
is hitting their bottom line and that
plastic bags are the only viable option
during the ongoing monsoon season a
customer who buys five lemons can put
them in his pocket but if he buys 50 he
can't carry them in his hands he needs a
bag with cloth bags if he buys 10 lemons
for 10 rupees it doesn't work for us to
give him a bag worth 2 or 3 rupees since
the banned customers have not been
buying vegetables from us they won't
take it wrapped in paper customers want
bags they say their stuff gets wet in
the rain and spoiled they love and are
mainly loved ocean but they now have to
get that's temperature to a fresh ah the
resistance the plastic ban is faced
isn't a surprise
he knows the mindset changes required to
get more people off single-use plastic
will take time until then he and his
team are moving their campaign beyond
the beach to businesses across the city
due to their efforts this restaurant has
invested in about 20 of these reusable
bags for food deliveries
shai is confident more will soon follow
suit and in doing so will also help
deliver a cleaner future for Mumbai